sur l'eau ma est une grosse banlieue de
san pedro sula la plus grande ville du
honduras de ce quartier seulement on
pense que 900 personnes ont pris la
route avec la caravane migrants vers le
nord tels norte les états unis la terre
promise
une grande famille de 20 personnes
vivaient dans cette maison d'une seule
pièce huit sont partis dans la caravane
à 1000 da était en contact avec les
quatre autres il ya encore quelques
heures
je ne sais plus où ils sont ils m'ont
dit qu'ils allaient prendre le train ils
sont peut-être dans le train la bestia
la bestia il est investi
à bastia on l'appelle aussi le trac
damman
cela fait vingt ans que les honduriens
quittent leur pays chaque jour ils sont
plus de 300 à prendre la route
la seule différence c'est que cette fois
elles sont sortis en masse en caravane
et api de san pedro sula
ils fuient la misère et surtout la
violence san pedro sula possède une zone
franche pour les entreprises étrangères
souvent des fabriques de vêtements pour
marcher comme la canadienne bill dann
on les appelle les maquiladoras ce ce
sont des dizaines de milliers d'emplois
pas bien payés mais recherché il attire
une population qui s'agglutinent en
périphérie de la ville
san pedro sula avait encore récemment la
triste réputation d'être une des villes
les plus meurtrières du monde
ici on se protège comme on peut chaque
matin les journaux affichent les grands
titres des plus sinistres capture d'un
assassin notoire fusillade dans un
billard le lendemain enlèvement et
assassinat d'un couple qui possédaient
des motos taxis
ils se sont plaints d'extorsion à la
police on les a retrouvés la langue
coupée
c'est comme ça tous les jours pas
partout mais en particulier dans ces
quartiers périphériques comme celle au
mas provençal et les occassions salon la
pauvreté ne cesse d'augmenter
pauvreté par manque d'éducation de santé
d'un petit bout de terre
on a faim il n'y a pas d'emploi ou des
emplois qui ne sont pas dignes d'un
plein
on n'entre pas dans le show l'oma avec
sa voiture si on ne veut pas la perdre
ni pour sa sécurité sans melania reyes
qui dirige le centre de protection des
femmes du quartier la police dépassée et
corrompu ne met jamais les pieds ici
c'est melania qui nous a conduits vers
la famille acosta à 1000 da n'est pas
partie car elle prend soin de leur mère
âgée
deux des quatre adultes dont son fils
alex miguel sont revenus avec deux
enfants malades
les autres idéalement ne reviendront
jamais dans la vie à quatre ans elle
confectionnait des beignets jusqu'à ce
qu'on agresse ses enfants qui les
vendaient pour les voler elle préfère
les voir partir
c'est la deuxième fois que carla tentent
de quitter le pays deuxième échec
maintenant elle se cache elle fait face
à plusieurs menaces celle du père d'une
nièce qu'elle a dénoncés à la police
pour avoir agressé sexuellement la
petite âgée de 6 ans l'autre menace
vient du mari de sa compagne julie ça
avec qui elle a rejoint la caravane à
cause de leur orientation homosexuelle
on l'a déjà tenté de la tuer elle craint
aussi pour sa fille qui est le fruit du
viol qu'elle a subi à l'âge de 16 ans
rien d'étonnant la violence sexuelle et
les féminicides sont récurrents ici cent
soixante douze femmes mortes depuis le
début de l'année c'est en arrivant au
pont à la frontière du guatemala du
mexique que tout s'est gâté pour
beaucoup de migrants journée de
confusion des migrants qui sautent dans
le fleuve sous chat et certains ont été
arrêtés par les autorités mexicaines
d'autres ont renoncé comme swami
castillo et ses trois enfants dans la
confusion générale une bande de marin a
voulu lui enlever sa fille aînée de 13
ans elle a préféré faire demi tour
elle se résigne à vivre en vendant les
tortillas maison quitte à repartir si
elle n'y arrive pas
les migrants hondurien savent qu'en
partant ils risquent leur vie c'est la
peur qui les pousse enyele minéraux un
mobile violentes au monde
la peur d'une mort violente la pauvreté
avec la violence suscite la peur d'une
mort violente pour leurs enfants à
n'importe quel moment
mieux vaut risqué sa vie en chemin qu'un
coup de feu ici et mes rôles qu'elle
aura des moyens communaux
ces migrants sont méprisés par l'élite
du pays
et pourtant l'argent que le million de
honduriens qui vit à l'étranger envoient
à leurs familles et la plus grosse
entrée de devises du pays
plus que la banane le café ou les
produits min
l'airé messages comme on les appelle
constituent 20% du pib
le produit intérieur brut pour leurs
compatriotes s'est exilé incarne le rêve
américain
le père jésuite ismael moreno estime que
sur neuf millions d'habitants cinq
millions sont sans emploi et sont
condamnés à la simple survie dirige
radio progreso la seule radio qui osent
encore critiquer le gouvernement
d'où les strictes mesures de sécurité
caméras partout et vitres de studio à
l'épreuve des balles
tous les gouvernements depuis 20 ans son
responsable de l'exode des honduriens
mais celui ci est le pire croit-il celui
de roanne orlando hernandez qui s'est
fait réélire en novembre dernier en
dépit de la constitution au milieu de
violentes protestations selon nos
sondages sept citoyens sur dix croient
qu'il ya eu fraude et que roanne orlando
hernandez est responsable de la crise
actuelle en plus lui et son groupe sont
des voleurs sont essentiellement de la
grogne contre la moitié des gens disent
que si ça continue ils quitteront le
pays comme donald rome qui l'a appuyé
dans sa réélection contestée le
président accuse des opposants d'avoir
organisé la caravane à des fins
politiques
en fait le 3 octobre cette affiche est
publié dans facebook et what's app
c'est une convocation pour la marche du
million rendez vous le 12 octobre à la
gare d'autobus la télévision rapporte la
nouvelle qui fait boule de neige
le jour dit des centaines de personnes
se présentent à la gare d'autobus et
prennent la route à pied vers le
guatemala
ce n'était pas prévu ni planifié mais
l'idée était que voyager en groupe
présentait moins de risques pour les
migrants
habituellement c'est avec les autobus
congo l'homme que les migrants partent
vers le guatemala surtout la nuit
ces jours ci la centrale d'autobus voit
surtout revenir des honduriens expulsé
par centaines par le mexique
cela ne les décourage pas melania
connaît quelqu'un qui est parti dans la
caravane
il a dû revenir iriez technicien en
réfrigération un bon métier mais il n'a
pas de clients ils sont trop pauvres
alors il va repartir
mieux préparés on sait surtout il aura
vu comment aura tourné laventure de la
caravane passe te ra a tenté le coup
deux fois avec sa fille
la première fois après l'assassinât de
son mari pour le volet la deuxième fois
le passeur qu'on appelle aussi coyotes
les a livrés à la migra mexicaine après
qu'elle et sa fille ait refusé ses
avances
si l'occasion se représente elle repart
demandez leur tout le monde veut partir
d'ici du pastora